[Musik]
eine oft das ksk ist die überzeugung
deutscher staatsbürger in krisenlagen im
ausland zu gewährleisten sind 22 jahre
hat sich das ksk als relativ
verschlossen abgestellt es gibt zwei
gründe warum jetzt hier sich geöffnet
wird zum einen ist es so dass wir serien
wie die rekruten oder mal die relativ
große erfolge verzeichnen konnten und
dass bewerber aufkommen der bundeswehr
erhöht haben
zum anderen ist es so dass es natürlich
auch dass k s cup auf der suche nach der
eigenmittel und qualifizierten nachwuchs
ist
wir haben jetzt den protagonisten namens
robert markley mal den wir eingekauft
haben dann hat er hier die zielgruppe
repräsentiert und das alles ein bisschen
greifbarer macht also was ich nicht
erwartet hätte dass mich die menschen
diese dahinter mir sehen dass sie mich
so aufnehmen dass sie mich so nah an
sich ran lassen dass wir nicht raus weil
es ist ein sehr verschiedenes kommando
eine geheime truppe und dass ich so tief
eintauchen kann das war schon für mich
sehr überraschend und ist auch ziemlich
cool
jeder dschungel ist speziell und zu
lernen was kann ich essen wie baue ich
mir eine unterkunft was ist für mich
gefährlich wie nutze ich den dschungel
als mein freund das ist das was ich hier
extrem doll mitnehme und für mich
anmelden kann dass es wirklich genial
der junge kann als freund sein oder den
feind sein
wir sind sehr stark bestrebt dass der
dschungel unser freund wird aber das
dauert seine zeit
also hier ungeübt versuchen sich
zurechtzufinden sehr sehr schwer gute
waffen jeden fall wenn man aufklärungs
auftrag hatten wir natürlich auch nicht
nur eine bewegung heißt sein eventuell
jemand im notfall auszuschalten auch das
leise zusammen ist oder für 30 9 x 9 mm
magazine ganz normal auch jeweiligen
anzeige 15 patronen
wir arbeiten ohne sicherung der
zeigefinger musste ausreichend und eben
das vertrauen zu den kameraden hier war
die geschütze macht die wahl für sich ja
noch mal bewährt haben
anders als molly aber mindestens genauso
genau so glaube ich für für die youtube
gemeinde das dschungel hat seine ganz
eigene und ich glaube dass das gras so
noch nie gezeigt werden man muss sich
vorstellen wie laufen sechs kameras rund
um die uhr
das heißt wir kommen mit etlichen steuer
1000 stunden zurück und daraus werden
dann eben halt 15 folgen ausbildungs wir
lassen nur die soldaten werten
entsprechen deshalb glaube ich im moment
ist die ehrlichste annäherung an die
bundeswehr gibt
[Musik]
ich sag mal so die gefahren sind halt da
ja das problem ist eben dass wir eine
hohe luftfeuchtigkeit haben die pflaster
halten relativ schlecht muss man sagen
die wunden eigenheit dazu sich schnell
zu infizieren deshalb muss man da besser
drauf schauen als daheim erteilt haben
wir hier die ganze kameraden viel schlaf
mit ihren hängen an der matif wird dann
einfach einem baum befestigt doch
regendach darunter haben wir die hängen
hatte hier oben ist es wir müssen
schlauer wir haben hier unten und
klettverschluss unsere dusche ein sack
mit wasser gefüllt hier kann man auf
drehen und dann wir uns auf stühle
gebaut
die sind auch bequem wir sind noch
stabil das kann man sitzen
jeder hat seinen platz die gruppe ist in
zwei gruppen unterteilt links und rechts
für maler und die erste die zweite
gruppe dementsprechend weiß auch jeder
muss ein ruck zuck ist tagsüber gibt es
keine privatsphäre und das ist auch gut
so
wir leben hier als kamerad und wir als
team und zu arbeiten wir auch unser
leben gemacht
[Musik]
das fahrzeug hat jetzt ein reifenplatzer
gehabt eine typische lage egal welchem
einsatzland wir uns befinden
auch das muss trainiert werden und ich
schaue jetzt an die abläufe ob das alles
so abläuft dass sie erst zur
eigensicherung schnell und effektiv
arbeiten
also man nach beiden kurzen halt kurzer
halt da sprechen wir von 10 bis 15
minuten
dementsprechend wird den vorn und hinten
rot abgesetzten fahrzeugen
da wird der sogenannte scheck allein
ausgelegt mit diesen flaschen dann wird
er fünf war durchgeführt das heißt wir
suchen schneckenförmig mit hohmann im
fünf meter umkreis um fahrzeug den boden
ab nach verdächtigen treten et cetera so
im endeffekt heidis oder rechen
sprengfallen
weiter wollten
[Musik]
hier ist die folge und nehmen
an baden
die
[Musik]
zweitens interessen bei gehabt
dementsprechend haben wir jetzt wenn
eintönig also ist was es beim abgebunden
kann damit die massen und blutige stockt
anderes bewusstsein verloren
the flood wenn ihr sprechen brauchen wir
ihnen gerne tun muss eingeführt so weit
ist jetzt stabil gestoppt
vitalfunktionen sind da und muss sein
ist allerdings nicht da wir warten jetzt
auf dem kesselberg bzw
helikopter der ist beim anflug der wird
in ca drei minuten hier sein verbringen
die patienten wie es jetzt in beirut
bravo an alle gruppen für sofort
reagiert aufsitzen weg hier die marke
brauchen großen und ganzen war die sehr
sehr gut gelöst
ich bin heute
[Musik]